ARE ON STANDBY.
MY CONVERSATION WITH
ANDREW CUOMO WAS A VERY
PRODUCTIVE ONE AND A VERY GOOD
ONE.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
WE ARE GIVING RELIEF TO AFFECTED
INDUSTRIES AND BUSINESSES.
WE EMERGE WITH THE PROSPEROUS
AND GROWING ECONOMY.
THAT IS WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT WE WILL BE STANDING POSSIBLY
UP HERE.
WE WILL SAY WE WANT TO MAX.
AND WE ARE GOING TO SAY THAT.
THAT SURE AS YOU ARE SITTING
THERE, WE ARE GOING TO SAY THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO WIN.
LATER TODAY, I WILL MEET WITH
THE LEADERS FROM THE TOURISM
INDUSTRY AS WELL AS INDUSTRIAL
SUPPLY RETAILERS TO DISCUSS
THEIR CRITICAL ROLES.
AS YOU KNOW, I MET WITH THE
DEPARTMENTS ARE A PEOPLE.
ALL OF THE RETAILERS, INCLUDING
WALMART AND OTHERS.
STALKING UP THEIR STORES LIKE
THEY HAVE NEVER STOPPED THEM
BEFORE.
WE ARE TRYING TO GET PEOPLE TO
ACTUALLY BUY MY CLASS, IF THAT
IS POSSIBLE.
BUY LESS.
THEY WILL STAY OPEN ALL HOURS OF
THE DAY.
WE ARE TAKING AGGRESSIVE ACTION
NOW.
AMERICA CAN REBOUND STRONGER.
FRANKLY STRONGER THAN EVER
BEFORE.
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT WHILE MANY
AMERICAN WORKERS CAN WORK FROM
HOME, MANY OTHERS CANNOT.
MANY OF OUR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS, FIRST RESPONDERS, MEN
AND WOMEN IN THE FOOD SERVICE.
THEY ARE SHOWING UP AND STANDING
UP TO PROVIDE US WITH THE GOODS
AND SERVICES WE NEED.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO STAY HOME IF
THEY CAN, BUT IN MANY CASES, YOU
TALK ABOUT FOOD SERVICE, CERTAIN
ITEMS IN PARTICULAR, THEY ARE